One of you is about to become our new Miss Universe.
If for any reason she is unable to fulfill her duties,...
...the first runner-up will take her place.
Good luck to both of you.
Miss Universe 2015 is Colombia!
Okay, folks.
I have to apologize.
The first runner-up is Colombia.
Miss Universe 2015 is Philippines.
Listen folks, let me just take control of this.
This is exactly what's on the card.
I will take responsibility for this.
It was my mistake.
It was on the card.
Horrible mistake, but the right thing,...
...I can show it to you right here.
The first runner-up is Colombia.
It is my mistake.
Still a great night.
Please don't hold it against the ladies.
Please don't.
We feel so badly, but it's still a great night.
Thank you all.